et j'accueille maintenant ils étaient
médaille d'or au relais messieurs djamel
bouras
alors donc djamel bouras médaille d'or
de judo jeux olympiques d'atlanta en 96
un an plus tard contre les positif à la
nandrolone
et vous parlez de ça dans un vent parler
donc dans un bouquin
à
on commence maintenant comment se dit
d'ailleurs très basse par l'histoire de
votre famille justement votre grand père
qui a fait 14 18
c'est pas mal de le dire ce à quoi on
est tout à fait en fait j'ai voulu faire
un je voulais raconter impoli d'où je
venais de mon arbre un peu commencé et
je crois que c'est important surtout je
voulais que les français de souche parce
que moi j'ai une double culture
je voulais qu'on comprenne une fois pour
toutes nos difficultés
c'est qu'en fait nous c'est à dire il
nous disait toujours qu'on est algérien
moi personnellement je suis né en france
mais mes parents d etat algérien on va
retourner définitif en algérie on n'est
pas chez nous ici en fait d'accord et
tout moi j'étais à la maison
bon c'est ça et lorsque j'arrivais
lorsque j'allais à l'école
bon tu étais de quelle origine bat je
suis algérien mais était né en france
c'est pas possible
à l'entrée on avait le cul entre deux
chaises convient donc il fallait acheter
le fallait trouver son canapé à quel âge
vous avez découvert le judo puisque vous
avez découvert le judo vous dites je vis
judo je dors judo je coure judo je ne
rêve que de combat et de victoire 6 à
quel âge ça j'ai commencé le judo
j'avais 8 ans et je pense que c'est vers
boost 12 13 ans c'est à dire que même
lorsque mon père nous avons assez
d'écoles mois le judo ça ne m'intéresse
pas son cd que lorsqu ils me donnaient
des livres et fallait je le résume les
chapitres un peu le soir marché
tellement les boues tient au bout d'une
demi heure je me rends compte j'avais
rien du coup j'étais dans une finale de
une compétition je ne sais pas 15 ans et
le première ceinture noire il est même
pas le droit de la porter parce que j'ai
du mal à 15 ans et 2 mois d'apporter à
16 ans et en 88 ans assez incroyable
dans le genre patient 88 vous voulez
tellement participer au championnat de
france vous avez une jambe cassée vous
casser le plâtre je suis non c'est je je
je je me fais une double honte ans l
arrachement du ligament et jeu pour me
mais le plâtre le soir même et mon père
qui me faisait 90 et le soir il a fallu
que je convaincs mon père pour qui le
soir même et massive mais enlever mon
plâtre si le plâtre je fais tout toute
une galère de rééducation avec le la
lampe qui me chauffe le pied
l'entraîneur qui me masset qui me sinon
pour moi lâche pas un franc c'était
foutu après vous partez à joinville plus
que beaucoup de sportifs vont bataillon
de joinville pour faire l'armée est là
justement l'alcool vous permet aux
viviers pas évidemment en tant que
musulmans chez vous et l'alcool vous
permet de faire partie du groupe de vous
intégrer un petit peu avec les autres et
c'est là qu'est cette scène terrible 593
au japon stage de de l'équipe de france
après une soirée arrosée vous avez un
ami qui se fait renverser par une
voiture et qui meurt le lendemain à
l'hôpital
jti la visite tous les deux avec amélie
bouillet la main dans la main oui c'est
que lorsque je suis arrivé à j'avais
16-17 ans et comme j'étais souvent dans
ma cité là bas où on est toujours entre
nous ils ont toujours fait ça pour qu'on
soit toujours entre nous de façon
lorsque je suis arrivé là à paris ça a
été une ouverture pour moi mais lorsque
j'arrive j'étais toujours entouré de
deux français de souche koualou de
chrétiens qui pourraient l'alcool
n'était pas interdit quoi que ce soit
mais moi je savais pas je croyais en
mieux mais bon j'étais pas pratiquants
et donc tout ça dès que les gens ont
commencé à boire moi j'étais au tour
alors ça rigolait pour pipi caca pour
n'importe quoi donc j'étais là toujours
en dehors je me dis je vais chez moi
j'étais là ça me alors je rentrais
toujours dans la chambre tout le temps
pourtant j'étais un peu seule et puis à
un moment donné je me suis dit bon bah
je façon je pratique pas je vais faire
partie de leurs tripes quoi et jusqu'à
un moment où il ya eu cet accident japon
et charles gave
je sais c'est de boire ouais j'ai étudié
g après j'ai commencé à lire des livres
sur déjà je me suis posé la question sur
la croyance servir s'il y at il un dieu
ou pas donc j'ai fait un peu des
recherches personnelles et puis ça aussi
c'est notre coeur qu'il me sens et pas
vraiment aussi une heure à la raison de
ce qu'on dit toujours que le coeur
dépasse la raison
j'ai été le premier musulman français
donc champion olympique en 96 et vous
dédiez votre médaille d'or au monde
musulman ça a choqué beaucoup de gens
sachent ce que des ouï mata sont
l'ignorance choque beaucoup de gens
toujours c'est pour ça qu'on dit que
l'ignorance engendre la crainte et la
crainte engendre la haine et le monde
musulman c'est qu'il ya beaucoup de
choses que je laisse comme g speed en
livre c'est quelque chose qui m'avait
choqué c'est tyler moi en tant que
musulman
lorsque c'est à dire qu'on n'était pas
on ne jugeait pas de la même façon
lorsque c'était une autre personne qui
est musulman je donne un exemple au
liban et ont tué il ya eu je fais à 104
morts à cette époque-là civile il y
avait beaucoup moins de morts je me
rappelle en israël il ya eu quatre morts
on a donné 100 millions de dollars à
l'assemblée nationale ils ont fait une
minute de silence jeudi qu'elle c'est
super c'est vous ce qu'on fait enfin peu
dans le monde c'est extraordinaire
alors et ensuite il ya eu 104 civils
morts et la personne n'a rien fait une
minute de silence et j'ai dit oui
pourquoi c'est comme ça il ya une autre
chose aussi qui m'a choqué que ce qui
m'a choqué c'est que en bosnie avec ce
qui se passait ben parce qu'il n'y avait
pas de pétrole et vais rien donc les
gens ne venaient pas là bas et en plus
il ya une autre chose ça si ça avait été
le contraire et j'en suis un peu
persuadé si ç'avait été les bosniaques
qui massacrent et les serbes on aurait
dit à les fous de dieu c'est en train de
massacrer les pauvres chrétiens ou les
frais et c'est ça que je n'apprécie pas
c'est que sur les 1 milliard 300
millions de musulmans dans le monde il
suffit qu'il ya un petit pourcentage
d'ignorants 10 ou de frings
convenablement musulmans mais beaucoup
en exergue les les intégristes et les
fondamentalistes parce que ça arrange
beaucoup de monde c'est pour moi c'est
fait exprès parce que souvent les
musulmans qu'on interroge aussi on
dirait qu'on l'ait choisie
parce qu'on a envie de montrer ça et là
beaucoup de musulmans qui sont très
sages qui sont très près plus qu'ils ont
un respect de la femme qu'il n'y a même
pas un européen
j'ai pas vu un européen amis européens
respecter sa femme comme ça et ça on le
montre jamais mais avouez que c'est rare
djamel bouras que des musulmans
s'exprime à la télévision en france pour
parler de la religion jeu à part le
dimanche matin quand je dors pourquoi
parce que wayne en est d'accord parce
que ouvrard pudeur ou c'est pas partie
de voir ce qui se passe à sait que c'est
mal dans la mentalité maintenant c'est
mal perçu
lorsqu'on dit les gens même ceux qui
sont musulmans en sont presque à dire qu
ils sont tellement ils auront de dire je
suis musulman je fais le ramadan je fais
6 ha bon parce que dès que disent ah bah
on croit en toi on se mêle un peu à
l'écart va qu'est ce qui va nous faire
il va nous c'est pareil pour les
catholiques maintenant quand quelqu'un
dit je suis catholique ont dit moi je
vais être de droite comme si être
catholique cet endroit que je pense pas
franchement beaucoup moins peut-être un
peu maintenant mais beaucoup moins et
c'est dommage je trouve
après mon train après votre victoire
évidemment les médias se sont jetés sur
vous vous parlez de juppé qui vous
attendez vous êtes à regarder l'utilité
là qu'il était l'acte on se faire
mousser
c'est clair je veux dire pourquoi j'ai
dit pourquoi je le dis ça parce que je
le pensais c'est à dire que tous les
sportifs déjà dans l'avion faisait sa
façon tellement les délais les sportifs
c'est la fête à l'intérieur tout le
monde est arrivé les chemises déchirées
torse nue faisant même pas personne n'a
vu juppé mais ils sont là - les enfants
personne personne n'a pas attention quoi
et puis ils sont là pour faire pour se
faire mousser
parce que dans dans mon épreuve les
preuves que j'ai eu jean net on en a
toujours deux façons mais dans l'épreuve
que j'ai eu c'est à dire que lorsqu'on a
besoin d'eux je parle pas de jupe et
pour tous les politiques
lorsque tu réussis de destins emblème le
commencement avec zidane tu vois sont
tous là si zidane il a besoin d'eux ils
sont là en garde à vous et vous savez
que le dernier et moi lorsque je les ai
vus lorsque j'ai eu mon ombre
enfin lorsque je suis revenu oui djamel
alors y'a pas de problème etc
tu vois comme tu veux ta famille tu
viens tout ce que tu veux tu vois et
quand j'ai mon problème excusez moi mais
je
je suis innocent il ya vraiment une
injustice en train de se passer et
serrage oui vous me servez les pas là il
en afrique là ils sont pas là tout s'est
bien passé sans doute ce qui nous a
c'est en dessous de ce qui nous a réunis
et puis comme j'ai un peu plus de
bouteille du tort je ne suis permis de
lui dire qu'il fallait peut-être avoir
un peu plus de recul parce que c'est
très difficile pour quelqu'un comme
duhamel qui a été touchée aussi je
voudrais juste si c'est possible que tu
montres tes mains à mes devoirs tes
doigts
mon plaisir parce que voyez pour pour
être champion olympique il a déformé ses
mains et regarder comment sont ses
doigts et donc quand on souffre comme ça
pour être champion olympique on a
attaqué il ya deux façons de réagir et
c'est vrai je parle sous contrôle de
jamel c'est vrai que par rapport à ses
origines par rapport à ce qui va il sait
il avait peut-être plutôt tendance à se
réfugier dans la haine plutôt que de
tourner la page et de démontrer
seulement qu'il était le plus fort et je
crois qu'aujourd'hui voix devant soi
quelqu'un qui est fort donc
donc quand il gagné cette médaille
faisait beaucoup de succès donc
évidemment juppé qui vous attend star ne
regardais même pas et le cinéma vous
tombe dessus
c'est un peu la même histoire que
florent pagny vous êtes tombé sur
dominique besnehard mais j'avais
rencontré avant d'être à vendetta avant
d'être proposé des rôles de maghrébins
beau gosse amoureux d'une bourgeoise
avec des scènes d'amour si vous n'êtes
pas branché on a proposé une dizaine
depuis on m'a proposé une fois un scénar
alors c'était soi disant voilà
maghrébins qui habite dans un village
qui sort avec toutes les filles et la
tombe il tombe amoureux d'une fille du
front national
superbe le public on va proposer un
autre je vous en donne un autre le
deuxième c'est le travail je te fais
livreur chez pizza etc
et puis je tombe dans un jeu dans une
banque je me retrouve avec une
bourgeoise et puis on a enchaîné tous
les deux et puis après on se retrouve en
amour que dès que les premiers rôles en
plus bas pour un début c'est super vite
la légion d'honneur brûlez pas refuser
légion d'honneur
pas parce que on peut monde en fils de
chanter la marseillaise pour commandes
il faut tremblay pour grandir et puis à
cette époque là quand tu es un peu dans
les nuages tu fais pas gaffe à plein de
choses et puis bon je déjà classé
rebelles comme ça je me suis dit bon si
je descends 96 j'essaie de dire beaucoup
de choses
alors si je me suis dit je me fais
remarquer encore pour ça il va également
savent à cela une mais ça va bien sympa
et c'est pour ça mais c'est vrai que la
mecque réflexion je me dis mais pourquoi
j'ai accepté
pour moi ça ça sert à rien une jambe
humeur je sais pas quand je vais appeler
quand j'ai zappé quand j'ai eu mon
problème ça ça passe a non seulement on
y arrive à vos problèmes et un chapitre
dans votive qui s'appelle heures lors du
beau temps lors des trahisons et vous
dites les amis du champion olympique ont
du mal à être ceux du dopé ma chance
dans tout ça c'est que je fais du sport
de combat donc dans la rue les gens
disent pas on va le dire fiat est doté
si parce qu'il en sait jamais s'il a un
peu fait des dessus de soi ça déjà ça
m'a sauvé un peu mais
le plus il a touché sa ma famille ça
lorsqu'on est un petit ressort qui
fermente c'est magnifique à 12 ans a
tiré à l'école à nice 1 1 et ça qu'il
revient en pleurant qui parle d'école
parce que tu as tous et pop indé c'est
compréhensible en plus un stage la façon
à 12 13 ans on est toujours un peu vache
et bisous l'iton frère c'est un tricheur
ou quoi que ce soit qui revient en
pleurant qui va pas à l'école pendant le
temps et où enfin ma mère la douleur
qu'elle a parce que même si j'ai beau
avoir maintenant 27 28 ans où je serai
toujours semblé bucquoy elle aussi un
problème et ses hommes il a bon quand
ils m'ont appelé m'ont pas dit mais
qu'est ce que tu as fait m'ont appelé
m'ont dit mais qu'est ce qu'ils t'ont
fait qu'est ce qui s'est passé et cette
fois cette fois là j'ai ma famille vous
savez il nous quand on jure
peut-être qu'elle voudrait pas que ça ne
veut plus rien dire leur canton jure sur
quelque chose on est obligé de nous
croire 60 mois gdd la médaille d'or aux
mondiaux qui se disent les musulmans
lorsque je quand je suis arrivé là bas
quand je suis descendue à givors je leur
ai dit tout simplement parce que j'ai
une fille qui s'appelle inès et j'aurais
dit que dieu
aujourd'hui il me maudissent moi ma
fille ma famille si moi j'ai fait ça ils
sont mis à pleurer enfin parce qu'ils
savent de quoi je parle
tu vas savait qu'à une société assez
grave c'est fort soyez thierry jam elle
vit quelque chose que tous les gens qui
ont été condamnés à un moment vive
il est aujourd'hui blanchi et pourtant
voulu reposer des questions sur son
passé et continue à y répondre
tu dois plus répondre à cette question
jamal parce qu'on a rendu sa médaille
donc ça n'a plus lieu d'être pour natal
c'est moi aujourd'hui j'ai appris une
bonne chose c'est que je vais l'amener à
chaque fois dans les émissions l'abri de
la lumière n'est pas terminé il ya
sydney je désirais ma victoire à tous
les djamel bouras de cette terre soit
quand même temps s'ils ne la signale
dans huit mois septembre septembre si je
le fais deux fois ce serait le seul
français à l'avoir fait
alors là je sais plus qui vont vous
faire j'espère je leur demande us and so
c'est de ne rien faire ne rien faire
avant pour que je puisse y aller mais
voilà merci à toi cet effet voilà bien
alors mon ami mais sûrement